si vous avez fait l'homme à votre image
j'aimerais comprendre pourquoi je me
retrouve comme ça avec un postérieur de
circonférence qu'on peut dire inhumaines
et en constante croissance
c'est une histoire de fesses ou plutôt
d'une métamorphose
celle d'un homme ordinaire un petit
homme gris sans envergure dont le
derrière va devenir énorme la mine de
cet homme là n'est pas tellement
marrante d'ailleurs il va le rappeler
plusieurs fois qu'elle est pas tellement
marrant de sa vie on est là pour
s'amuser pour s'amuser de ce personnage
est de 7
cette aventure parce que c'est une
aventure qui peut être drôle mais mais
mais pas seulement
un conte surréaliste pour parler de
thèmes bien réel j'assure l'intégration
ça notre place la place de chacun dans
la société la place de chacun au milieu
des autres
comment comment la trouvez comment
éventuellement l'a gardé quand la perdre
écrite et mise en scène par pierre note
la pièce prend la forme d'un monologue
riche et maîtrisez pas de décor pas
d'effets spéciaux l'imagination des
spectateurs fait tout le travail
chaque individu dans la salle a sa
propre histoire se fait sa propre
histoire avec ses images ses couleurs
ses références donc évidemment que les
gens après spectacle me dit ça me fait
penser à ça moi ça me rappelle ce à moi
ça me rappelle sa pire des choses
on parle de kafka walt disney de paris à
dieppe du métro un cirque itinérant
une épopée aux accents fantastiques les
voyageurs sont attendus pour
l'embarquement à elancourt fesci
puissant
ici comme dans la jungle avec les
éléphants il ne faut jamais rien fixé
trop longtemps ma petite fille apprend
ça entre deux sanglots et un astéroïde
sûrs de tomber l'eau